And you know,
this,
this last question,
it's not really a question.
What would it look?
I get a lot of awesome emails and I get emails from people that have completely
turned
their lives around.
They've,
they've lost weight.
If they needed to lose weight or they've gained weight because they needed to
gain weight or they've gotten promoted or they've become a better parent or they
become a better spouse or they become a better kid.
Yeah,
yeah.
And I get emails from people that have quit their addictions or they've,
or they've overcome their fear and I say,
what?
I get letters and packages and notes about all this kind of stuff.
Then it's awesome.
I get,
I get people send me books for the podcast and pictures and drawings and,
and,
and military memorabilia or unit patches and coins from police departments and
fire departments and,
and military units.
It's just,
it's awesome.
And,
and I,
um,
I'm so thankful for all that feedback
and it,
it drives me bad feedback that I get,
drives me to work hard and keep pushing to do this to the best of my ability and
try and get better at it.
But
you know,
I,
I hear from people that have used the podcast and the discipline and the,
the,
the mindset of looking at things that are problematic as being good.
I hear from people that have used those things to overcome,
you know,
dark patches yeah.
In their lives.
No,
whether it's depression or anxiety or even like full fledged despair.
And again,
when you hear from people that are turned that corner,
that's just incredibly rewarding
to know that there's,
you know,
there's people out there that are really changing for the better and turning
their lives from negative
to positive.
It's unbelievably rewarding.
But I also get
some other emails and I get some other messages
from people that haven't been able
to dig out of that hole to overcome that,
that despair.
I hear from people sometimes that fuel Vitters nowhere,
nowhere else to go.
There's no way out.
And they don't have any more options
and they are considering
taking the only way out that they can see.
And that is they want to take their own life.
Okay.
And
to anybody out there that's in that place,
you know,
I don't really know what exactly to tell you,
but I can kind of tell you what I think.
I think.
No,
I think,
no,
I think don't save that last bullet for yourself.
Don't save it for yourself.
You lock and load that last bullet and you shoot it at your enemy.
And when you're out of bullets,
get out your knife and attack with that.
And if you lose your knife,
grab your enemy by the fruit and you keep fighting
and you keep fighting and you keep fighting and you keep fighting no matter
what.
And you never quit.
Never,
never
quit.
And if you feel like your wife isn't a place where you can't get any lower
and you don't think you can find any way out,
good
cause that means the ultimate challenge is ahead of you.
It means you can only go up.
And it also means that things are going to be tough.
Things are going to be tougher than anything you can imagine,
but that storm you're in from,
from your perspective,
it seems like that storm is enveloping the whole world,
but I'm telling you,
it is not
the storm that urine.
It is hard to see out of that storm.
It's hard to see past it.
It seems like the storm,
it seems like the storm is everything,
but the storm is not everything
Andy alone last forever.
You can get out of the storm and you will get out of the storm,
and when you get out,
you're going to see this sauna.
Okay,
but right now you're being tried.
You're being forge.
You're being tested by fire and by pain.
That's the test.
Don't fail the test.
Don't give in.
Don't quit.
Yeah.
Don't ever quit.
Fight on
fight through the storm.
Fight through the pain and come out the other side.
Stronger and tougher
and better.
A fighter,
a survivor,
oh,
winner.
Victorious
and
free from that storm.
Free from the darkness.
Free.